hello freak bitches you have amateur
fights yeah I fought in the amateurs and
dude there was a time when I thought you
know and I think that's why I can you
know deal with the fighters and I
understand you know like dealing with
the Ultimate Fighter there was a fucking
time in a day when there is the only
fucking thing I cared about was boxing
that's why I literally walked out of
that place because I loved it so much
that that's all I fuckin wanted to do
the problem is you go out there and you
start fucking you know that that's what
I wanted to do for a living and then the
reality starts to set in and I'll never
forget I mean I I've told the story
before but I was in the gym one day and
there was this dude who was a local
fighter I don't say his name
you would probably fucking know if I
said his name I guarantee you you know
because he was famous in the Boston area
you know like a local guy and he came in
one day and he was like he's in his
early 30s he was like 31 or 32 and he
was fucked up you know he was punchy he
fucking moping around kind of throwing
fucked on ice I remember the day that I
looked at my said fuck what if that
happens to me and then the minute you
fucking start thinking like that you're
you're you're not the real deal you're
not no matter how much you think you
want it or you think you do was the day
I realized that I wasn't and I was
fucking like wow so then you start going
how the fuck am I going to make a living
doing this and me and this dude Peter
Welsh from Boston started you know
teaching people how to box basically you
know businessman and stuff because the
business model wasn't if first it's like
martial arts if you want to take a
martial arts class
it's fucking 50 martial arts studios
anywhere in any city anywhere in the
world there has been since I was a kid
right any mmm lack of martial arts
schools around your place when you were
growing up no so if you want to buy but
if you want a box you got to go and
fight go get your fucking head punched
yeah
you know enemy especially you know the
places in Boston oh yeah yeah the
Somerville boxing club you had the
fucking place down and don't McDonough
down in South Boston yeah yeah and and
and some play the petrol Nellie's down
in Brockton yeah in places like that and
you went in and they would fucking you'd
get your dick knocked loose right if you
came back
maybe they'd fucking work with you but
even guys that liked you would do that
like I got I got trained by Joe Lake and
that's that's what he did with me he
just stuck me in with guys in a box they
all do good luck be that who they all do
yeah yeah that's they do it quickly -
like what right right from the beginning
find out how much you enjoyed doing this
do you really want to do this waste of
my time here - exactly right I'm gonna
teach you how to throw some punches and
then we're gonna put your headgear on
let me put your fucking Vaseline on your
face in there kid show me what you got
the first time I ever went into box they
had me do fucking ring circles you know
what those are right we go laterally
around the ring fucking coming in every
day that ring circles ring circles ring
circles ring circles and I was like the
fuck I paid my dues I paid my fucking
eight bucks you know what I mean
oh I fuck you got mad one day I said I
came here and learned how to fucking box
me I've been running around in circles
for fucking weeks he's like oh you want
to wear my box right yeah fucking get
like fucking geared up man
love yep they throw you in there and
they beat the fuck out of you yeah
fucking drop me 50 times with body shots
punching my fucking head in the worst of
the body shots when you first started
you start taking some body shots from a
guy who knows how to throw them and you
know your fucking lips are bleeding your
nose is bleeding you're fucked up you
get out you're completely morally
destroyed you know what I mean because
boxing is never or sparring is never
what guys thinks it's going to be you
know you watch too many fucking movies
you go in and you think you're going to
spar and you get chick Tatia but then
you know I went home that night and I
remember laying in bed thinking the
whole night fuck I got my ass whooped
that slug was that and I went back to
the gym the next day and that was it
there it's not working with you very few
people actually want to fight they just
want to kick someone's ass surely they
understand that kind of kick your ass -
like this is not going to be an even
exchange and if you're not willing to go
to war if you're not willing to take
like big shot
and be in pain and push through you're
never going to do this this is you you
have to figure out somewhere along the
line whether or not you willing to take
punishment whether or not go through
punishment some guys can so that was
what I bought what our business was
based on you know to be Peter I yeah you
could come you could come into the real
gym where real fighters trained and you
learn how to box just like white-collar
Bob yeah so it was like you learn how to
box but you didn't get your ass kicked
every day but some guys you know start
train for so long and get to the level
where they want to start sparring but
you rarely ever have white-collar guys
that start sparring to want to do it if
I can get you know like say you get that
first ass weapon and and a lot of times
what happens is it breaks and breaks out
into fights you know and we had we used
to we used to bring the inner city kids
into you know we had this idea we're
bringing inner city kids and you know in
Southie back then it was still very
segregated so we're going to bring in
blacks and Hispanics and all these other
kids and bring them together and you
know we're going to do all the fuck we
used to bring these kids in man and we
start training them and stuff and then
as soon as guys would start sparring you
know how many fucking situations we had
were guys would come back in with bats
like there'd be a bad sparring deal come
back with bats or they come back with
their brothers or some kind of just
every fucking day that was so that whole
let's bring in the inner city kids and
fucking try to where it didn't go over
well yeah that's plain that experiment
and then work to that's a lot of work
it's interesting to see the the attitude
you know that used to exist back then
the boxing gyms and now that people are
where we're seeing this evolution in
mixed martial arts where the beginning
we saw a lot of like gym wars like that
would be like a really normal occurrence
in gyms where guys would just beat the
fuck out of each other you hear about
fighters getting knocked out in the gym
left and right left and right but now I
think people are starting to realize
like well there's no fucking benefit in
this like what's going on here like
we're gonna we're looking at a gigantic
multi multi multi-million dollar
business and this is how we're treating
our commodities and our prospects
where we're throwing them at each other
and let them blast each other and dudes
are getting punchy way before their time
we we both know gyms where guys they get
Chinee way too quick and you go well
how's this guy like would this guy had
an iron changes three years ago I was
taking fucking gym wars he's going
through gym wars on a regular basis yep
that was shoot the box that was the deal
at shoot the box and Shogun himself said
like we realized you know after doing
that for a while we can't do that
anymore
we iight that's how it wasn't boxing to
that when I when I was involved in
boxing some of the best fights I ever
saw her in the gym oh yeah you know oh
hell yeah one that one day I saw a a
Livingstone bramble and Roger Mayweather
oh fucking go at it at a fucking gym in
Vegas yeah another time why one of the
gyms because because we all work
together I worked with Mayweather I
worked with Nick one kick arm Floyd when
Floyd was first coming I mean we all
work together in these gyms you know and
uh one time there was this dude he was a
heavyweight his name was Tracy and him
and Roger Mayweather fucking got into it
he was Tracy was a young heavyweight 24
year old kid heavyweight and Roger was
fucking 147 yeah in his 40s geez I just
like what you say motherfuckers it's at
the fucking gate into it both off back
and forth I go shit here we go and I got
in the fucking ring and start a fight
man yeah yeah they started fucking
fighting and at the end of the round
when the bell went off Tracy tried to
stop and Roger fucking lit him up and he
goes no rounds motherfucker
no round so they just kept fighting
straight fucking through until fucking
Tracy quit oh my god Roger fucking
whooped his ass and he fucking quit and
it's in 40s yeah and then and then when
he quit Roger hit him another eight nine
times after he fucking quit and he's
basically like don't have a fucking
mouth off to me in this gym a 147 pounds
40 year old yeah but Roger a black mamba
yeah you know a lot of people don't know
Roger you know a lot of people everybody
knows Floyd but Roger his uncle in his
time he was
bad motherfucker he had a piston right
hand yeah he had a nasty jab and he
would fucking slam that right hand in he
was a bad dude for many a year I've seen
some crazy shit happen in fucking champ
boxing gyms man crazy shit